depuis les universités des mairies de
l'ouest parisien à port-marly merci de
nous rejoindre à nouveau aujourd'hui 13
octobre les collectivités et leurs
partenaires se réunissent pour évoquer
différentes problématiques auxquelles
ils font face au quotidien nous allons
aborder l'une d'entre elles au cours de
la prochaine demi heure nous allons
aborder la question de la sécurité en
plateau thomas la vielle bonjour vous
êtes seul le directeur de cabinet du
préfet des yvelines sous préfet nicolas
dainville bonjour à vous mr de la
verrière vice-présidente saint quentin
en yvelines et puis le lieutenant
colonel rémy moulinier de la gendarmerie
merci aussi de nous avoir rejoints et
vous allez participer on va débuter avec
vous dans quelques instants une table
ronde portant sur la question de la
cybercriminalité de la vidéoprotection
également on a le sentiment aujourd'hui
que les élus les maires sont de plus en
plus confrontés à ces problématiques de
sécurité au sens très large quelle est
la réalité du terrain aujourd'hui et
comment intervenez vous également
alors il est vrai que la réalité du
terrain était un peu diverses l'année
2020 effectivement a été très
particulière pour tout le monde vous
avez parlé effectivement des tables
rondes tout à l'heure sur la prévention
il ya également de gestion de crise
c'est vrai que l'année 2020 était
marquée notamment pour les maires par
deux phénomènes c'est une impression
parfois les populations les plus
reculées d'un certain délaissement et
dans ces cas là les on se retourne
naturellement vers vers les mers et la
gendarmerie qui sont les institutions
les plus le plus proche est
effectivement
faut pas écarter non plus phénomène des
agressions des maires pour lesquelles
nous avons dû être très présent
j'écoutais hier effectivement les les
statistiques ont annoncé des 200 % de
bon sens de haut sur les agressions de
mer de l'est mer voilà donc nous nous
partageons avec les maires cet ancrage
territorial donc pour nous pour être au
plus près notre population il est
naturel que on est ce dialogue constant
permanent avec les maires et quand je
parle d' ancrage territorial pour nous
on habite également dans ses mails
danser dans ces villages et dans ces
villes donc
d'être à l'écouté nos mères d'être à
l'écouté de la population
durant cette période plus très
particulière la gestion qu'ovide ça nous
a permis de mettre en place pas mal de
dispositifs innovants donc merci à vous
de nous inviter merci à vous également
merci à lui mis de manière générale ce
qui nous a permis de présenter ces
dispositifs aujourd'hui ces dispositifs
on les souhaite sur mesure c'est pas des
dispositifs clés en main et on a pour
rôle évoluer tant sur le plan physique
que sur le numérique comme vous les
appelez je rappelle juste que les
agressions des maires qui sont
effectivement connaissent un boom
formidable malheureusement se font beaux
également énormément dans le
sur le numérique les gratifications
numérique les violences wikia les
réseaux sociaux ont connu un boom un
baume vraiment extraordinaire donc voilà
cette coproduction de sécurité que nous
voulons avec les maires c'est vraiment
aujourd'hui en plus à un moment
privilégié pour y parler puis pour voir
débattre tout l'après midi rappelle que
vous intervenez effectivement
aujourd'hui sur les différentes tables
rondes et puis à travers vos stands
aussi vous allez à la rencontre des des
élus des collectivités vous évoquez tous
les dispositifs qui peuvent exister
nicolas dainville sur la problématique
de la sécurité aujourd'hui quelles sont
les difficultés que vous rencontrez le
plus souvent et puis peut-être bondir
aussi sur ce qui a été dit avec ses os
d'agression envers les élus de plus de
200% ces derniers mois effectivement
vous avez près de 1300 agressions de
toutes sortes des élus l'année dernière
donc je plus de 200% comme l'avait dit
on le vit au quotidien c'est beaucoup
d'inventivité sur les réseaux sociaux
parfois un déferlement de haine des
menaces en tous genres c'est parfois au
plus proche du terrain lorsqu on
verbalise un dépôt sauvage lorsqu'on
enlève une voiture ventouse lorsqu on
verbalise un problème de stationnement
souvent parfois malheureusement les
maires les élus en général
se voit opposer une réaction très très
hostile
donc effectivement je pense que la
notion de deux peines plancher contre
les agressions envers les forces de
l'ordre les policiers les gendarmes les
élus pourraient être une solution à
réfléchir pour la prochaine campagne
présidentielle
sur les incivilités c'est vrai qu'on
on est sur le terrain en permanence il
ya les incivilités que j'ai évoquées
dépôts sauvages et parfois
malheureusement un sentiment
d'impuissance des maires face à des
réalités qui les dépasse notamment les
occupations illégales de terrains par
les gens du voyage encore récemment dans
ma commune c'est vrai qu'on a eu on a du
mal à y faire face de manière
satisfaisante rapide la problématique
des squats aussi où les mères sont
souvent un petit peu démunis
heureusement les services préfectoraux
sont réactifs mais ce sont des
procédures très longues je pense
qu'aussi y aurait une réflexion à avoir
sur le caractère inviolable de la
propriété privée pour être beaucoup plus
réactif et ne pas avoir parfois c'est
trêve hivernale qui complexifie
énormément les procédures d'expulsion et
puis sur un certain nombre de
problématiques notamment les rodéos
c'est vrai que parfois on a aussi ce
sentiment d'impuissance on constate les
faits on les filme on transmet les
images mais on a du mal à lutter plus
durablement plus efficacement avec la
confiscation du véhicule donc je dirais
qu'on est en première ligne on est
souvent les victimes effectivement
d'agression mais on est malheureusement
un puissant et on s'appuie beaucoup sur
les services de l'état sur les services
de l'ordre mais je pense que la justice
pourrait être plus rapide et plus
pédagogue dans dans la sanction à porter
mais on voit que les problématiques de
sécurité vous occupe au quotidien dans
votre notre mandat de maire et je vais
me tourner vers le représentant de
l'état forcément sur cette problématique
là on entendu un témoignage de mr qui
nous expliquent être démuni le plus
souvent face aux différents sujets de
sécurité qui peut rencontrer comment
l'état intervient à travers la
préfecture je crois que c'est justement
important aujourd'hui à l'occasion de
l'université des mères qui est le moment
de deux partages de formation des
changes des mères avec leurs partenaires
publics ou privés de mettre ce sujet au
coeur de au coeur de nos échanges parce
que on parlait tout à l'heure de
coproduction de sécurité aujourd'hui on
est vraiment dans cette situation-là et
malheureusement et on y est très
vigilant à versailles les atteintes
qu'ils peuvent touché des maires sont
liées aussi au fait qu' il monte en
première ligne et qui s'investissent des
sujets et ça montre justement que la
sécurité est aujourd'hui une matière co
produite et dans trois domaines à mon
avis et trois domaines clés qui sont en
tout cas ceux autour desquels on
travaille dans le partenariat avec les
maires la prévention de la délinquance
est une mission du quotidien assurée par
des associations mais coordonnés par les
maires porté par les maires et qui est
vraiment aujourd'hui essentielle avec
des publics jeunes qu'il faut distraire
de la délinquance au plus vite le
deuxième angle c'est les atteintes à la
tranquillité publique je parlerai pas de
la lutte contre la délinquance qui à mon
sens
est encore et doit être du ressort des
forces de l'ordre et de l'état mais les
atteintes à la tranquillité publique on
parlait des voitures ventouses ont parlé
d occupation illicite de la voie
publique on peut parler de l'ouverture
illégale d'établissements recevant du
public toutes ces atteintes qui causent
des troubles
de voisinage et des troubles à la
tranquillité publique sont également des
domaines dans lesquels les maires sont
en première ligne
et puis le troisième le troisième
domaine qui nous préoccupe beaucoup qui
est pour l'essentiel une responsabilité
de l'état mais qui nécessite un dialogue
permanent avec les maires c'est la lutte
contre la radicalisation et la
prévention de la radicalisation notre
département a été frappé à plusieurs
reprises par ce phénomène à magnanville
en 2016 à conflans 2020 à rambouillet en
2021 plusieurs territoires avec des
morphologies très différentes ont été
touchés et donc dans cette matière là à
la fois sur la lutte contre la
radicalisation violente mais aussi
contre ce qu'on a appelé le séparatisme
c'est à dire le communautarisme exacerbé
le refus des valeurs de la république on
a besoin d'un dialogue permanent avec
les maires pour signaler des situations
difficiles et ensuite pour échanger sur
des structures qui nous paraissent
devoir être accompagnés pour rentrer
disons dans le giron républicain va
revenir sur cette thématique de la
radicalisation sur la prévention en tout
cas puisque vous allez intervenir vous
cet après midi de sion on va reparler
dans un instant mais par rapport à
aujourd'hui les dispositifs qui peuvent
exister ce qui nécessite une
modernisation de ces dispositifs ya des
nouveaux contrats qui sont mis en place
des contrats de sécurité intégrées par
exemple est-ce que ça concerne le
département des yvelines est ce que ça
fonctionne qu'est ce qui manquerait
aussi pour que cela puisse fonctionner
nicollin dainville déjà en tant que
maire aujourd'hui votre constat est
votre demande c'est quoi plus de moyens
plus de dispositifs quelque chose
fonctionne mieux on a l'impression que
les choses sont mises en place mais pour
autant les résultats derrière n'arrive
pas encore
alors il ya des choses qui fonctionnent
à la verrière pour ne parler que des
plus belles communes des yvelines on a
expérimenté les adultes relais sur la
médiation et ça fonctionne très bien
avec des profils qui vont dans nos
quartiers qui vont parler aux jeunes qui
connaissent les parents qui peuvent
faire ce travail et la parentalité pour
mieux les responsabiliser donc ça
clairement ces deux dispositifs
financé à 95 % par l'état qui fonctionne
les bataillons de la médiation je pense
qu'ils sont mis en place qui
j'en suis persuadé feront feront leurs
preuves après c'est vrai que sur la
question des moyens je pense que il ya
un vrai travail à faire sur le le nombre
de forces de l'ordre puisque on regrette
depuis un certain nombre d'années
avec importe les majorités qui se sont
succédé quand même une diminution des
effectifs et puis des commissariats ou
des casernes de gendarmeries
vieillissante m'assurer long cours c'est
un commissariat qui accueille mal les
victimes qui accueille mal les policiers
qui dans un état honnêtement assez
honteux et qui nécessite un vrai travail
de modernisation
c'est le directeur de cabinet lui seul
près fait parler d'eux de rambouillet
c'est vrai que là la femme qui est sorti
de rambouillet qui a été assassiné c'est
effrayant effroyable je crois que
c'était pour remettre un disque dans son
véhicule sur un parking non sécurisés
donc c'est vrai qu'on a cette
problématique au site sécurité de nos
forces de l'ordre dans des territoires
qui sont pas faciles et donc il faudrait
que nos commissariats no futur
commissariat
intègre davantage la sécurité de nos
forces de l'ordre et puis puisse
accueillir les victimes et nos policiers
dans des conditions je dirais de travail
optimisées sur les moyens l'état y
répond de nouveaux dispositifs sont mis
en place mais ce que des agents des
forces de l'ordre arrivent en plus oui
je fasse chaud sur les sur les moyens on
l'a dit il ya eu une une décrue des
moyens des forces de l'ordre sur une
longue période il ya eu un coup d'arrêt
qui a été marquée puisque à la fin du à
la fin de la période qui vient à la fin
du quinquennat des investissements
nouveaux ont été faits sur des effectifs
qui arrivent dans les yvelines parce
qu'on a plusieurs centaines de policiers
notamment de gendarmes aussi
qu'ils vont investir nos commissariats
nobrega le miso l'intérieur ait eu
l'occasion de communiquer sur le sujet
mais évidemment ça veut pas dire que
c'est suffisant qu'il faut qu'il faut
pas faire plus qu'il faut pas réinvestir
sur le commissariat d'elancourt
puisqu'on parle de celui là mais c'est
vrai de manière générale de pas mal
d'implantation c'est vrai aussi de
certaines brigades de gendarmerie qui
nécessite de travaux très lourds
des choses sont en cours qui vont sans
doute insuffisamment vite mais un
nouveau commissariat est en projet à
elancourt une nouvelle brigade est en
projet à mantes la jolie voilà les
choses vont trop lentement mais mais
nous y travaillons et côté de la
gendarmerie justement sur ce constat sur
les moyens qui peuvent manquer
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous vous sentez
quelquefois un peu démunis si vous vous
dites que les choses vont dans le bon
sens aussi quand on entend le
représentant de l'état alors pour la
gendarmerie c'est vrai que nous avons
une sac à dos un peu particulier puisque
nous avons toute la partie immobilier
qui nous occupe beaucoup
je dois dire bon avec mon expérience de
plusieurs groupements enfin plusieurs
départements que nous avons un
accompagnement que je qualifierais de
remarquable ici puisqu'on a beaucoup
d'emprise
sur lequel le conseil départemental est
propriétaire et je dois dire qu'on a une
écoute et un suivi qui est assez
exceptionnel et qu'on doit souligner le
directeur rappelait le cas de mantes la
jolie je sais que le président bédié
particulièrement attentifs à ce dossier
vous évoquez rambouillet on a eu la
chance d'avoir un plan particulier de
protection de l'emprise d'une la
compagnie qui est juste en face
du commissariat où malheureusement notre
collègue est décédé et nous avons
d'autres projets effectivement donc les
les feux sont quand même bien pousser
sur le plan de l'immobilier sur le plan
de l'effectif des effectifs nous ne
sommes pas non plus le groupement le
plus à plaindre
pour une autre question aussi ses bêtes
c'est que c'est simple pardon c'est que
le groupement des yvelines pour la
gendarmerie est assez attractifs ce qui
peut parfois poser souci c'est
l'encadrement des intermédiaires les
cadres et ça c'est à nous de les former
de les fidéliser puis qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient effectivement
réactif voilà donc il ya beaucoup de
choses beaucoup de travail qui est
toujours en place toujours en cours on
parlait du dialogue avec les maires il
compte beaucoup un autre présence ici
c'est la journée pour nous il faut pas
rater puisque c'est aussi grâce au maire
grâce aux élus que tout ça est possible
deux thématiques pour pour terminer pour
évoquer lors de cette table ronde de ce
plateau pour tv 78 toujours depuis port
marly la question de la cybercriminalité
justement parce que vous allez
intervenir dessus d'antenne quelques
instants à cet après midi ici au
complexe pyramide
aujourd'hui les collectivités
connaissent des formes nouvelles de
délinquance on a vu dans les yvelines
aussi des communes les sites internet
sont piratés attaquer là aussi c'est une
nouvelle mission pour les élus et pour
les mères quel message vous fait passer
et quels dispositifs existent alors déjà
il ya un constat il ya deux constats
même la gendarmerie a investi bien sûr
depuis un moment le
le champ de la cybercriminalité c'est à
dire que nous avons des avants
commandement du numérique nous avons des
enquêteurs spécialisés
donc ils font la chasse aux
cybercriminels au sein du département au
sein de la section de recherches de
versailles il y à des cellules
spécialisées qui travaille là dessus il
ya une deuxième un deuxième effet on
parle de gestion de crise la crise qu
vide aussi nous a appris beaucoup face
parfois effectivement aux difficultés
qu'ont eue les mairies à relancer leurs
systèmes informatiques on a été amené à
proposer l'an dernier ainsi un programme
innovant de d'hygiène
d'hygiène de leur bureau puisque nous
avions des personnels nrbc qui ont pu
effectivement donné quelques conseils de
gestion de l'hygiène des bureaux dans le
cadre du cockpit pour rouvrir
effectivement les mairies où certains
certains centres également nous avons
proposé les premières marches d'une
hygiène informatique quels sont les bons
réflexes effectivement à avoir a
conservé la première étape surtout que
dans 980 mairie en zone gendarmerie y'a
pas toujours des services peut-être
comme monsieur le maire à la verrière
qui a desservi un peu plus conséquent
pour pour gérer ce type de difficultés
donc pour la gendarmerie fiction on a
fait cette offre de service d'hygiène
tant physiques matérielles et numérique
et ce principe a été fait à prospérer
puisque avec le soutien de la mf
maintenant nous avons un programme bien
complet est effectivement en
accompagnement très très très appuyé de
mairie j'invite d'ailleurs à la table
ronde de 15 heures où on aura quelques
illustrations des des outils qu'on
propose au maire voilà vous avez
peut-être suivi aussi
le problème qui a eu la mairie d'angers
effectivement il ya une attaque cyber
attaque cyber qui a paralysé les
services de la ville donc c'est vrai que
ce réflexe de sécurité numérique
doit être vraiment irrigué doit vraiment
irriguer un peu la réflexion de nos
mères et nous nous y employons en
donnant quelques outils déjà dès les
premiers instants pour pour nos mères
pour la question de la cybercriminalité
en tout cas des difficultés de
sécurisation de tous ces réseaux
internet sur la ville de la verrière par
exemple aussi c'est une problématique
réelle bien évidemment leur sert et que
nous on est une petite commune donc on a
on a peu de moyens on essaie de
travailler beaucoup en coopération avec
saint quentin en yvelines les
intercommunalités
mais c'est vrai que c'est une
vraie une un vrai risque qui n'épargne
aucune entité entreprise collectivité
avec de la ville de baltimore aussi qu'a
connu une attaque d'une ampleur très
très importante donc effectivement on
sensibilise on essaye de se protéger au
maximum et c'est un risque qu'on prend
en compte multiplier les casquettes en
terme de sécurité et d'incendié à les
éteindre un régulièrement sur le terrain
est l'un des sujets que vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure qui va nous occuper à
présent c'est la question de la
prévention de la radicalisation alors
vous attendez beaucoup aujourd'hui des
mères vous vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure pour l'état mais est
concrètement que fait un maire et
comment ils détectent des signes de
radicalisation et comment il intervient
alors sur le sujet de la radicalisation
il ya deux dans le sujet de la radio il
ya deux choses ensemble il ya le sujet
des personnes radicaliser à potentialité
violente des personnes qui sont
susceptibles de passer à l'acte de
commettre un attentat
ces personnes là sont suivis par des
services de l'état le maire n'a pas de
rôle dans le suivi de ces personnes là
il a un rôle dans la détection et je
vais y revenir et puis un deuxième
ensemble qui est je le disais la lutte
la prévention contre le séparatisme le
communautarisme exacerbé l'idée qu' on
se soustraient aux activités de la
collectivité aux activités associatives
pour vivre en vase clos et se renfermer
se renfermer aux règles de la république
et le maire dans cette cette lutte
contre cette prévention contre la
radicalisation de ces deux de ces deux
éléments le maire il a un rôle dans la
détection le maire connaît ces familles
le maire les connais par l'école il les
connaît par les activités périscolaires
il les connaît par le tissu associatif
et donc il a des capteurs fin que non
pas des services de renseignements des
services de police des services de
gendarmerie qui eux aussi connaissent le
terrain mais sans doute pas avec la même
finesse individuel puisque encore une
fois le maire va inscrire les enfants à
l'école il valait connaître
individuellement ce qui veut dire que
par exemple eu un enfant qui à l'école
primaire va tenir des propos qui ne sont
pas de son âge qui sont déplacés ou à la
suite d'un attentat des propos déplacés
ça pose une question pas sur l'enfant
mais ça pose une question sur
l'environnement familial dans lequel il
se trouve et ça ça nécessite des
remontées d'informations évidemment par
l'éducation nationale mais aussi par le
maire le deuxième rôle dans le dmr en la
matière c'est un rôle de prévention
c'est à dire que au delà de ces
situations individuelles il ya la
nécessité aujourd'hui de lutter contre
le complotisme sur les réseaux sociaux
lutter contre la diffusion de fausse
information
promouvoir le bon rapport à l'image chez
les jeunes et à la vidéo toutes sortes
de choses qui peuvent contribuer à une
autoradicalisation
des jeunes face à des vidéos sur
internet le maire l'a aussi dans son
rôle d'interface avec le tissu
associatif a un rôle de prévention et
puis troisièmement
le maire a un rôle dans la prise en
charge
sociale éducative
deux jeunes qui sont en risque de
radicalisation je parlais tout à l'heure
de l'exemple d'un enfant dans ce qui
serait placée dans un contexte familial
sensible évidemment avec ce qu ont
évoqué le la présence sur le terrain la
présence
de travailleurs sociaux la présence de
médiateurs et une capacité
d'intervention et de suivi de ces
familles pour essayer tant que faire se
peut de les sortir du risque de
radicalisation sur votre commune dans
votre mairie les éducateurs médiateurs
sont sensibilisés à ces questions là
est-ce que vous intervenez est-ce que
vous avez déjà eu des échanges aussi
avec la préfecture alors c'est vrai que
nous notre commune on est limitrophe à
trappes qui a malheureusement connu une
vague de départs pour la zone irako
syrienne plus de 80 jeunes 67
officiellement il ya la première idée
retour donc c'est vrai qu'il faut qu'on
travaille ensemble
de manière coordonnée tous les services
pour détecter des signaux faibles
sur la verrière je dirais que ça se
passe plutôt bien c'est vrai qu'avec les
médiateurs qui ont été formés aussi
à tous les enjeux de laïcité on a eu une
formation des la préfecture à la fois
pour nos médiateurs mais aussi pour nos
agents donc on est formé sur sur sur ces
enjeux là sur ces valeurs là est
peut-être mieux armée qu'auparavant pour
détecter des signaux faibles et
effectivement travailler de concert avec
les services de la préfecture les
services de l'état on a des points
réguliers on allait les groupements
opérationnel partenariaux tous les mois
avec la police nationale on a des
contacts
quasi quasi quotidien avec les services
de l'état on a la chance d'avoir la
déléguée du préfet dans notre ville donc
je dirais que ça se passe plutôt bien
avec une coordination de l'ensemble des
acteurs qu'ils soient de l'état où
qu'ils soient locaux et on en à voilà
envie que cette collaboration continue
est ce que pour conclure la sécurité au
sens très large on en parlait
radicalisation on a brossé le tableau
assez large de cette problématique est
ce que la question de la sécurité
l'un des enjeux principal de ce mandat
de maire bien évidemment nous c'était un
ras-le-bol un ras-le-bol des habitants
sur une situation qui gît qu'il jugeait
trop laxistes une volonté de remettre
des règles des règles claires qui soit
appliqué les mêmes pour tous qu importe
le degré de parenté ou de connaissance
avec l'individu on a une vraie
difficulté sur le recrutement des
policiers municipaux on a je crois à
près de 1500 postes non pourvus en ile
de france et c'est une vraie difficulté
pour les petites communes avec des
postes qui sont pourvus dans les grosses
communes qui savent mettre les moyens
qu'ils savent jouer parfois sur les
heures supplémentaires pour payer
davantage
les agents qui savent aussi avoir les
moyens pour les armées ou pour les
accueillir au mieux et c'est vrai que
c'est une vraie difficulté pour nos
petites communes d'être attractif d'en
attirer et et ce serait un vrai besoin
de de pouvoir répondre à cette
thématique avec des équipes voilà plus
plus plus étoffé on a la chance d'avoir
deux médiateurs mais il faudrait
maintenant qu'on met l'accent sur la
police municipale et c'est ce à quoi on
s'attelle très bien justement j'ai
peut-être vous faire réagir sur la
police municipale tout de même on entend
ce manque de moyens l'état peut aider
intervenir
l'état peut aider sur les aides à
l'équipement ça c'est le fait
régulièrement on le fait avec la commune
de la verrière avec plein d'autres
communes
l'état peut aider en
simplifiant alors c'est pas l'état
préfectoral mais l'état national en
simplifiant je pense les règles qui
s'attachent à la
l'équipement des polices municipales la
possibilité pour eux d'agir il faut sans
doute simplifier davantage les règles
qui permettrait de recruter plus vite de
recruter plus simplement et
effectivement d'armé plus vite nos
polices municipales très bien merci
beaucoup à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce plateau je vais vous
libérer puisque nous sommes en direct et
dans quelques minutes vous allez
rejoindre différentes tables rondes
merci de nous avoir suivi sur tv 78 pour
ce plateau depuis port marly